The dream of the pneumatic tube will never
die.
They’re a few quirks from mainstream —
an oddity at bank drive thrus, a retro vision
of a smokeless and frictionless future.
But the hope lives with inventions like the
Hyperloop that try to combine pneumatic tubes
and maglev for high speed transport,
The thing most people don’t know is how
long the dream has been alive — and that
they’ve been trying to move people for more
than 150 years.
Pneumatic tubes are pretty simple.
At their most basic, a sealed tube allows
a fan to make a vacuum.
When a canister pops into place, a fan whirs
to life and creates a difference in air pressure
that sucks the tube to its destination.
As early as the 1850s, people adapted artificial
vacuums for powering the mail system, and
they sent lots of packages — including cats.
Part II
The New York City underground pneumatic mail
system launched in 1897.
It carried the mail from one post office to
another.
The first cannister had a Bible, a flag, and
a copy of the Constitution.
As an inside joke, the second carried an imitation
peach.
The third had a black cat (it survived).
Operators called themselves “Rocketeers”
and at its peak the system could send 200,000
letters an hour.
It wasn’t close to the first.
Pneumatic mail systems were surprisingly common.
They’d been running in London since the
1850s, and were in Paris, Prague, Philadelphia,
and tons of other places.
But as cities spread out and automobiles developed,
tubes became too difficult to install, maintain,
and staff.
They saw more widespread adoption in department
stores, offices, and yes, banks.
NASA used tubes for memos.
As interoffice mail, tubes were more practical,
until smaller offices and email made them
an extravagance there, too.
But the dream was always bigger than that.
They wanted to put people in the canisters.
Part III
Before the mail was the pneumatic railway,
including New York’s first subway system,
30 years before construction of today’s
familiar underground subway began.
Opened in 1870, Alfred Ely Beach’s experimental
subway debuted under Broadway, modeled on
experiments in England.
It sold more than 400,000 short rides as just
an experiment: for New Yorkers of the era,
it wasn’t a subway —
It was an advance in civilization.
Like London’s Crystal Palace atmospheric
roadway in the 1860s, it promised easy, clean,
transport.
But Beach’s proof of concept closed before
more stations could be built.
Investors got scared.
There was no pneumatic disaster, just reality.
The same thing that eventually took down the
mail took down the pneumatic subway.
It wasn’t easy or cheap enough to be sustainable.
The airless tube had too much friction.
Pneumatic tubes are still around.
Until 2011, they were used in at least one
McDonald’s drive-thru.
And they’re still used in hospitals to transport
lab samples
quickly and safely from
one floor to another.
But it’s the Hyperloop that has the original
spirit, the conviction that the pneumatic
tube isn’t a pipe dream.
It’s the idea part Victorian, part Jetsons:
that tubes won’t just push people from one
place to another,
But maybe into the future, too.
Any history of pneumatic tubes is going to
involve a lot of omissions.
I had to leave out the trash disposal on Roosevelt
Island, pneumatic dating, and also the pioneering
pneumatic mail in Philadelphia, where they
sent a rooster, guinea pigs, and a goldfish
in a goldfish bowl through the pneumatic — and
none of them were injured.